et puis ottawa va injecter 20 millions
de dollars pour aider les entreprises du
centre-ville d'ottawa qui ont été
affectés par les manifestations des
trois dernières semaines chacune d'entre
elles pourra recevoir jusqu'à 10000
dollars en subventions cette aide est la
bienvenue mais plusieurs commerçants
souligne qu'elle ne couvrira qu'une
petite partie de leurs pertes
financières on retrouve clos bonnet ce
soir qui est le propriétaire de la
boulangerie le moulin de provence pour
soir monsieur bonnet on sent le souffre
et nathalie carrier qui porte parole de
courbillac c'est la coalition des zones
commerciales de tahoua bonsoir
monsieur bonnet d'abord vous avez deux
boulangeries 1 devant le parlement
l'autre au marché by on vous a vu à
quelques reprises au cours des dernières
semaines vous avez été frappés comme
d'autres commerçants de plein fouet vous
allez ouvrir demain vaubourg boulangerie
c'est ça oui on qu'on recommence
tranquillement demain puisque bon bien
me demande à voir où est vraiment
opérationnel qu'au normal ouais avez
vous perdu beaucoup d'argent depuis
trois semaines mais à écouter depuis le
28 janvier vraiment on a été vraiment
parce qu'à 0 les premiers jours et après
ça ce site arrêté complètement comme un
mur donc ses pertes totales vraiment
depuis le 28 janvier c'est qu'on peut
dire c'est une perte totale et dans quel
état s'en vont financer en ce moment est
ce que vous êtes capable de reprendre
vos activités
bientôt espérons le pour vous
normalement
écouter au niveau des actifs et
financière
c'est ce que ça va être un gros trou à
boucher définitivement 28 jours 126
normes 28 jours pour supporter loyers
les taxes les remises et savait
l'administration comptablement que ses
membres pour toute entreprise c'est
énorme de le choc au niveau du
portefeuille donc les liquidités pour
beaucoup ça va être difficile en ce qui
me concerne moi je suis en opération
depuis 35 ans alors j'ai quand même un
plan b mais quand même il faut il faut
être très stratégique en ce moment c'est
à ça que ça sert des plans b des plans
c'est justement quand on vit ce genre de
choses là nathalie carrier vous
représentez les 19 zones commerciales de
tahoua ckoi l'importance de tout ce qui
s'est passé sur toutes les entreprises
la région l'impact s'est fait sentir à
l'extérieur bien sûr du périmètre de m
station je pense que nos entreprises ont
quand même vécu de huningue près du site
de suite à coville est et ce qu'il faut
je pense considéré dans cette situation
là c'est que cette crise-là des quatre
dernières fins de semaine a été encore
pire parce qu'on avait pas de cueillette
sur place on n'avait pas de livraisons
possibles
les magasins étaient carrément fermé il
une raison pour nourrir ses magasins et
la soie de nourriture ou des faits de
produits complètement bloquée alors on
entendu monsieur monnaies
je le connais car monsieur man et j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas le plan b
mais peut-être rendu au grand x y et z
ouais et du mois qu'on entend de nos
entreprises c'est que ça fait plusieurs
produits qu'on a et est ce que vos
entreprises sont capables êtes vous
capable de nous chiffrer l'ampleur de
l'impact économique de ce qui vient de
se passer
c'est dans les milliards dont alesi
monsieur n'est pas dangereuse que je
pensais que ça a été pour moi l'autre
coop pour pour pour moi tant que tel
c'est un commun quantité que difficile à
décrire maintenant mais dans les
prochaines semaines on va établir nos
pertes mais c'est sûr que au niveau
global bon j'attends je pense que pour
la région d'ottawa si c'est les millions
c'est des dizaines de millions de pertes
problème beaucoup le madame karine
l'esprit dow a perdu pendant la première
semaine 20 millions de dollars on
multiplie sa part 3 3 semaines et demie
plus tôt que les autres entreprises on
se retrouve presque dans les centaines
de millions c'est quand même très très
très important il faut se le rappeler là
c'était les entreprises qui était
complètement fermée ouais alors quand le
gouvernement dit 20 millions pour aider
les commerçants d'idole à dix mille 10
mille dollars maximum par commerçants
monsieur bonnet est ce que c'est
suffisant non bien sûr vous constatez
avec ces chiffres c'est absolument
insuffisant c'est une goutte dans
l'océan vraiment il faut vraiment qu'une
révision des évaluations des dégâts et
qu'on puisse avoir des gens qui fassent
l équation vraiment pour conclure je
vraiment beaucoup plus serré là pour
avoir des justes valeurs les compenser
madame carrier est ce que vous savez
vous aussi à d'autres types de soutien
qui sont à venir
wiltord qui est bon et on apprécie
beaucoup le large qui en effet des roues
il faut se le dire du monde alors c'est
quand même c'est quand même pas rien ça
peut dépanner un loyer ou on se rendre
aux prochains mois ce qui est ce qu'on
cherche alors on remercie quand même les
fédéraux pour ça mais il ya encore de la
haine qui est nécessaire et qui devrait
venir on espère bientôt de nos collègues
ont fait au
niveau municipal
aujourd'hui c'est le jour de la famille
en ontario sur un congé férié
généralement une belle fin de semaine à
ottawa il ya beaucoup d'activités divers
là bien sûr c'était pas possible c'était
pas possible en fin de semaine c'était
pas possible aujourd'hui madame carrie
est ce qu'on est capable de quantifier
ce que ça veut dire ça ce jour de la
famille qui n'est pas vécue normal vol
ne regarde d'habitude le jour de la
famille c'est le dernier jour de bal de
neige donc on a des familles qui nous
viennent de partout dans le pays et de
partout dans le monde pour venir
justement aller sur le canal aller
visiter monsieur monnaie s'appelle
pâtisserie dans le marché by etc des
restaurants pleins des magasins plus on
refait de l'argent comme on l'a pas fait
depuis juste avant noël et on a manqué
il faut cela pour la saint valentin une
grosse journée commerciale et par les
restaurants on a aussi manqué la fin
duquel la fin du canada perdreaux la
fête de la famille souhaite bonne fête
du canada parce que nous ce serait très
long minutes pas mais ce qu'on situe la
kozah qu a fait un sondage qu'on sait
c'est que 74 de nos entreprises ont fait
des pertes énormes pendant pendant cette
crise là là et que 52% de 10 qui
pourront pas récupérer l'argent qu'ils
étaient perdus puis on sait que 40% de
nos commerces dans l'est dans les zac
centrales qui ont fermé leur porte
carrément
monsieur bonhomme je veux terminer avec
vous les barrières
sont levés au marché by nous disait ton
il ya quelques heures mais encore des
policiers partout bien sûr il ya encore
des barrières métalliques et des
contrôles routiers est-ce que vous
pensez que ça va prendre du temps selon
vous avant de retrouver la normale je
pense que oui parce que physiquement il
ya quand même une inquiétude la du futur
pour la crise actuelle et je suis bien
content du les services de sécurité ils
sont en train de vérifier de mettre la
ville sous vraiment autres sécurité pour
qu'ils aient pas de rebond dans cette
crise donc c'est clair que l'on fasse
attendre encore sûrement quelques
semaines d'après d'après ce qui est la
stratégie policière pour revoir la ville
vraiment complètement et à 100% que est
vraiment une dernière question madame
carrier est ce qu'on craint d'autres
manifestations la
regardons aussi qu'ils sont juste à
l'extérieur de la ville et des centaines
de camions qui sont encore à vankleek
hill ailleurs on sait que les
organisateurs appellent quand même lol à
leur manifester à venir
à venir on est loin d'être sortis de
tout ça les mesures de guerre je pense
que c'est clair on en avait besoin
jusqu'à ce que ça n'arrive alors nous
s'est il faut vraiment se le dire long
je pense que c'est dû aussi pour les
gens qui sont pas tarder à voir de
vraiment comprendre ce qu'on a vécu ici
mais c'était vraiment un siège c'était
impossible nos transports en commun
étaient fermés les employés proposeront
au travail en plus des bipeurs de
sécurité il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup dangereux absolument on vous
entend bien merci d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir
bonjour à vous